would either of you guys be open to
revisiting the roles of chloe and
lucifer doing a netflix movie of some
sort the only spin-off that would not
work from the show would be a decker
[Laughter]
[Music]
i could see other characters having a
super successful epic spin-off but um
i don't know muff what do you think if
we did a little
i mean i think i i i
for now like this is the end of the show
as we know it i think that um you know
never say never there's always something
i say
and the notion of maybe doing a little
loose of a movie one day i'm not against
the idea but i think you know the show
as we know it in the show that we fell
in love with that has run its cause for
sure now that we do know that rory
exists of course we do have trixie we
know that charlie gets
his wings
do you think that there is the potential
of a spin-off with all these children
oh
oh
gosh i think so i mean never say never i
feel like great characters will always
have a second life so
never say never you know i would love to
see a maze eve team up where they have
their own bounty hunting business and
you know obviously i would love to
you know have ella
just be on the case and
even become a detective one day and and
yeah charlie half angel and i i mean
these characters are so rich that i
think
i think never say never so if netflix
comes to you and says we're ready you
know in five years to do a movie
you're ready to play ella again yes uh
absolutely
like no
i would i would just like no contest no
hesitation she is one of my favorite
characters i have ever played
and i love what she stands for and what
she represents and um
i
i would i'm going to miss her would you
ever revisit this role in some capacity
or
want to participate in possibly a
lucifer netflix movie if the
if the script and the timing was right
yeah i mean i don't i don't i don't see
how any one of us could say no i think
it's got to be something that the fans
ask for i think we all need to go off
and you know do our own things now as
artists as
parts
of uh family
i'm a dad to
an 11 year old that's getting ready to
turn 45 so
so i've been thrilled the last few
months to just be able to spend all of
this time with her so i just think that
we all need some time to spend with our
families and to move on to some other
interesting projects but the answer to
your question is yes when the day comes
that people want to see a
lucifer movie or or see where these
characters have have ended up they don't
even have to call me just tell me
you know where and when to show up and
uh i'll be there of course i love this
character i mean don't hit me up in 10
years and my hips aren't working
i'm joking a lot of women
were kicking ass you know mally berry
50-something like shooting an mma movie
and directing it hell yeah um but yeah
absolutely i love
love this character i think on our show
we've certainly squeezed out as much of
her story as we possibly could but
who's to say with you know in another
world and time there isn't more to to
tell no i i would i love me i've always
loved her
what about a spin-off i mean we've met
rory this season we know that charlie
got his wings there's of course
trixie what about a spin-off focused on
the kids
hey
uh
have your people call my people
you know um i never say never it's
hollywood you know i just who knows i
like i said i love this character and if
i was so blessed to you know have an
opportunity to reprise the role like
absolutely
[Music]
you